desde que el ser humano inclinó su
cabeza hacia las estrellas tuvo el
anhelo de pisar la luna como una muestra
de poder el reto fue protagonista de una
rivalidad geopolítica en una carrera
librada por Estados Unidos y Rusia creo
que esta nación debe comprometerse a
lograr la meta de antes de que se
termine esta década colocar un hombre en
la luna y retornarlo a salvo a la tierra
ningún programa espacial en este periodo
será más impresionante para la humanidad
o tan importante para la exploración del
espacio a largo alcance el programa
tendría un nombre mitológico Apolo el
presidente Kennedy fue asesinado ocho
años después de presentar el proyecto y
no pudo observar el triunfo
pero Estados Unidos dio un paso gigante
en nombre de la humanidad el honor
correspondió al comandante de la misión
Apolo 11 Millán después del viaje de
Armstrong 12 personas pasearon por la
desolación de los campos lunares el
último en hacerlo fue Eugene sernan
prometiendo volver en paz y con
esperanzas para toda la humanidad antes
de cumplirse 50 años de esta promesa la
NASA lanza un nuevo programa lunar
llamado artemis hermana de Apolo en la
mitología griega como parte del nuevo
proyecto el lanzamiento del cohete space
lunch System portador de la nave orión
abrirá una nueva página en la historia
de la exploración espacial la meta para
el hombre en esta ocasión es el espacio
profundo